Jesse Owens said we all have dreams in
order to make dreams come into reality
it takes an awful lot of determination
dedication self-discipline and effort
[Music]
self-discipline self-discipline when I
make myself behave you know how rare
that is in a culture that's obese in a
culture that is I mean cuz I can't make
myself behave I just like chocolate chip
cookies I mean it's rare to find
somebody that actually doesn't spend
money that they don't have to buy things
that they don't need to impress people
that they don't really like
self-discipline self-control these are
things that require you to understand
that things things like no is a complete
sentence no it's the ancient word that
will set you free no one's allowed to
say it anymore you're not allowed to
tell anyone no they'll immediately be
angry at you if you tell them no because
they have a right they are entitled but
no no no it is a powerful word that will
set you free your friends want to go out
to eat again and you're broke no I
really love that smell of that toxic
plastic in that new car oh I love it I
want at least one No
I'm gonna go to college and study
left-handed puppetry and go into debt
$250,000 no no you're not I'm gonna go
out of state and pay triple and going to
debt just because I went across the
state line my education will be exactly
the same as if I'd stayed in state but
I'm going to pay triple to go across the
state line and I can't afford to do that
so I'm gonna go into student loan debt
not from my education but because I want
to cross the state line and then I'm
gonna say I want in the student loan
debt to get an education and then I'm
gonna [ __ ] that College is too
expensive and rip me off
because I was stupid no no no I'm gonna
look at my eight-year-old and I'm gonna
teach them self-control by first
teaching them control know you're going
to behave in restaurants you're not wild
animals we are not raising wolves here
we're raising people who are gonna be
good adults you're going to learn to
control your little self and until you
do I'm going to control you that's why
they call me daddy that sounds like
child abuse no it's not you sound like a
wuss and you're part of the problem of
the culture if you said that no
self-control
self discipline first comes from control
and from discipline no discipline seems
Pleasant at the time but it yields a
harvest of righteousness
Hebrews No I'm gonna live like no one
else so that later I can live and give
like no one else I'm gonna have the
emotional maturity to delay pleasure
which is a sign I'm a grown-up and I'm
eight fifty seven year olds we're still
walking around with twelve year olds
inside of them making their decisions no
it's the ancient word the ancient word
that has seldom uttered in our culture
anymore but it will set you free and it
is a complete sentence the first thing
you do is you push your tongue towards
the roof of your mouth you blow air past
and you release and it sounds like this
if you've not used it in a while tried
it it's gonna sound funny the first time
if it comes out of your mouth no it's
been removed from several dictionaries I
suspect the politically correct police
will have it removed from our culture or
have you put in jail if you use it soon
no no no you can't do anything you want
no you cannot misbehave at that level
not without consequences no self
discipline self control it's hard this
grown-up stuff is hard I wish we could
all be little children and there'd be
somebody to take care of us but if
everybody's a little children then
there's nobody to take care of all the
little children so some of us have to be
grownups no you can't be a child anymore
no you're 27 you can't live in my
basement because an eagle who stays in
the nest too long is known as a turkey
no you have to leave no I love you too
much to allow you to sit here and grow
no wings and not be who God intended you
to be God did not intend you to intend
for you to be a Nintendo expert you need
to leave my basement
some of you desperately need to love
your child enough to do that no they can
write a blog about abusive parenting
from someone else's basement no and then
interesting this whole thing about
growing
and that's what we talk about here every
day on the show directly or indirectly
is am I ready to delay pleasure to win
Dave I want to change the rules can I
change the baby steps no because you
can't change the baby steps you don't
get to make up new math rules you're not
the exception I know everyone's unique
but you're not the exception the law
gravity applies to all snowflakes there
are each unique but they all fall down
there are certain laws and certain
principles that work every time one plus
one always equals two and you're not
special enough to change that I know God
thinks you're special but I don't you're
not special enough to change that you
have to abide by the law of gravity it
works every time I have to abide by the
law of gravity it works every time and
as soon as I align myself with truth and
function in that truth and function
according to those principles the pain
starts to leave and the prosperity
starts to come as soon as I start
planting corn and I'm not shocked that
corn grows Wow I have reaped what I have
sown self-discipline if you want wheat
you shouldn't probably not plant corn if
you want wealth you should probably
avoid debt all the data points tell us
that if you want a high-quality marriage
you should probably not lie to your
spouse about hiding money duh why is
this hard it's hard because we're humans
and we like chocolate chip cookies all
of us have a little kid inside of us and
we all push back against that little kid
every day but the more the little kid
wins the Dumber we are the more immature
we are and the more pain we have in our
lives no self-discipline Dave you
changed my life
no I didn't it's not a true statement I
made you believe you could
and I showed you how and you went and
did it but I didn't change your life
I didn't pay off any of your debt I
didn't cause you to being everyday
millionaire you did all of that you're
the hero in the story and I'm really
proud of you and those of you that
haven't done it yet I believe in you I
know that you can do it because I know
these principles work and I can't wait
to talk to you when you're winning
because you can do this stuff